Queridos amigos de Visualpolitik, creo que
la mayoría vais va a estar de acuerdo
conmigo: conseguir una democracia de calidad
no es una tarea nada fácil.
En nuestro mundo hay, sí,muchas democracias,
pero desgraciadamente pocas de calidad.
[Evidentemente cuando hablo de calidad me
refiero a un sistema democrático que respete
la libertad individual, la seguridad jurídica,
la pluralidad política y… todas estas cosas]
Pues bien, entre otros muchos, existe un principio
básico, un principio que es esencial en toda
democracia de calidad y que no suele gustar
nada, absolutamente nada a la mayoría de
los políticos.
Estoy hablando ni más ni menos que de la
alternancia; algo imprescindible para evitar
que una sola persona o un grupo de ellas terminen
convirtiendo a las instituciones, a los gobiernos,
en su rancho particular.
Es precisamente por este motivo por lo que
en muchos países existe la limitación de
mandatos.
("Nada es tan peligroso como dejar permanecer
largo tiempo a un mismo ciudadano en el poder.
El pueblo se acostumbra a obedecerle y él
a mandarlo, de donde se originan la usurpación
y la tiranía”. Simón Bolivar)
Amigos, tratar de impedir la alternancia política
a cualquier precio es algo que se ha hecho
desde siempre y con cierta frecuencia en todo
el mundo.
Y en los últimos años ha sido América Latina
la región que ha visto cómo muchos políticos
se las han apañado de una forma u otra para
mantener el poder a toda costa.
Políticos como Daniel Ortega en Nicaragua,
Juan Orlando Hernández en Honduras o Nicolás
Maduro en Venezuela.
Ahora, el último actor en sumarse a esta
lista parece estar siendo el Presidente de
Bolivia, Evo Morales.
Y la pregunta que hoy muchos se hacen es,
¿Esta la democracia boliviana en peligro?
¿Qué es lo que está ocurriendo? ¿Por qué
está siendo tan polémica la candidatura
de Evo Morales? Atentos.
(PROMESAS Y APEGO AL PODER)
El 22 de enero del año 2006, Evo Morales se convirtió
con más del 50% de los votos en el primer
presidente indígena en los 193 años de independencia
de Bolivia.
Su llegada al poder, os lo hemos contado aquí
en VisualPolitik en un vídeo que os dejo
en la descripción y también al final de
este, significó el fin de la exclusión política
para la mayoría de la sociedad boliviana.
[De hecho, desde una perspectiva histórica
creo que se puede decir que la llegada al
poder de Evo era inevitable.]
(El caso es que con su discurso de izquierdas,
en contra del imperialismo Yankee, en favor
de la participación política de los pueblos
indígenas y la nacionalización de los recursos
naturales, Evo Morales se propuso liderar
toda una transformación del país, una transformación
que contó con un amplísimo apoyo popular.
Para lograr sus objetivos el gobierno boliviano
apostó por algo que ha estado muy de moda
en Latinoamérica durante los últimos años:
¡Cambiar la Constitución!
Algo que, por cierto, también hizo con un
amplísimo apoyo popular, porque lo cierto
es que elección tras elección Evo Morales
arrasaba en las urnas).
Pero… volvamos a la Constitución, a la
Constitución del propio Evo Morales. Y visto lo visto,
vais a flipar porque esto es lo que decía su artículo 168.
(“El periodo de mandato de la Presidenta
o del Presidente y de la Vicepresidenta o
del Vicepresidente del Estado es de 5 años
y pueden ser reelectas o reelectos por una
sola vez de manera continua”. Artículo
168 de la Constitución boliviana)
Está claro, ¿Verdad? De forma continuada
una persona solo puede ejercer el cargo de
presidente durante dos mandatos. Y cada mandato
dura 5 años.
De esta forma, como Evo se presentó en 2009
a la reelección, su tiempo en el gobierno
debería haber concluido en 2014, ¿Verdad?
Son matemáticas básicas.
Pero, pero… un momento… aquí hay algo
que no me cuadra.
Es el año 2018, Evo Morales sigue en el poder
y se va a presentar a la reelección en las
elecciones de 2019.
Entonces, ¿Qué diantres ha ocurrido? Atentos.
(LA REELECCIÓN INDEFINIDA)
Amigos, esta es la historia de cómo un hombre
se enamoró del Poder.
Vamos a ver, la propia Constitución de Evo
establecía la alternancia como un principio
necesario en el funcionamiento democrático.
Pero... nada más aprobarse la nueva Constitución
ya empezaron las problemas.
Evo dijo que a ver, que el mandato anterior
no contaba porque se había producido bajo
otra Constitución... que cómo el estado
boliviano se había refundado había que poner
el marcador en cero.
[A ver, esto es un poco absurdo. La alternancia
no se establece como un castigo sino como
una forma de evitar que una persona esté
demasiado tiempo en el poder.
Y si tu crees en ella y la introduces en la
Constitución que tú mismo has liderado...
pues la tendrás que respetar, ¿no?]
Pues.. No. Nada de eso.
(El caso es que Evo Morales consiguió que
una controvertida sentencia el Tribunal Constitucional
le diera la razón.
Según esta sentencia, Evo había sido el
Presidente de Bolivia, pero ahora lo quería
ser del Estado plurinacional de Bolivia, que
no es lo mismo, así que podía gobernar durante
dos mandatos consecutivos.)
¿Veis la diferencia? De la noche a la mañana
Bolivia, la Bolivia de siempre había desaparecido.
Esto es lo que explica que Evo se presentará
a las elecciones de 2009 y a la reelección
en 2014.
Pero, ahora sí que sí, ya no podría volver
a presentarse.
Ojo, el propio Evo lo dijo en muchas ocasiones,
dijo que en 2019 dejaría la política y abriría
un restaurante.
Pero... esperad un momento... porque sí,
eso del restaurante suena bien, pero ¿seguir
en el poder? Amigos, eso a Evo le sonaba mucho
pero que mucho mejor.
Así que en 2015, apenas un año después
de la reelección, diputados afines al Presidente,
presentaron una propuesta de reforma de la
Constitución ¡De la nueva Constitución!
¿Adivináis para qué? Pues ni más ni menos
para que el presidente y el vicepresidente
pudieran ser reelegidos dos veces, es decir,
para que Evo pudiera volver a presentarse
en 2019.
Sin embargo, en esta ocasión el tiro le salió
por la culata. La reforma salió adelante
en el Parlamento... pero tenía que aprobarse
también mediante referéndum... y, sorpresa,
Evo lo perdió.
(¿Usted está de acuerdo con la reforma del
artículo 168 de la Constitución Política
del Estado para que la Presidenta o Presidente
y la Vicepresidenta o Vicepresidente del Estado
puedan ser reelectas o reelectos por dos veces
de manera contínua? Pregunta del referéndum
constitucional de 2016)
La pregunta era clara y las respuestas aún
más: Si o No. Si a la reelección o no a
la reelección.
Y, amigos, los bolivianos dijeron que No,
Pero, llegados a este punto, os hago una pregunta,
¿Qué creéis que hizo Evo Morales?¿Aceptar
el resultado del referéndum y la Constitución
que él mismo había liderado?
Pues... frio, frio.
El líder indígena, el político que iba
a devolver la soberanía al pueblo, de repente
vino a decir que bueno, que a ver... que el
pueblo había sido manipulado... que tampoco
había que tenerlo muy en cuenta. Eso sí,
a pesar de todo, una vez más prometió respetar
los resultados.
Ahora bien, ¿esta vez iba en serio o no iba
en serio?
Pues…No, tampoco.
(Aprovechando su control sobre las instituciones
- precisamente lo que trata de evitar la alternancia
- Evo consiguió algo inaudito:
El Tribunal Constitucional Plurinacional,
el órgano que tiene que tiene que interpretar
la norma fundamental, en su sentencia 0084/2017
declaró inválidas partes de la propia Constitución.
Para justificar tal medida se recurrió al
Derecho Internacional y el Tribunal Constitucional
se dedicó a valorar y a interpretar la Convención
Americana de Derechos Humanos, la Jurisprudencia
de la Corte Interamericana… todo menos la
propia Constitución nacional.)
Al final el resultado de todo este experimento,
es que los artículos que molestaban a Evo
Morales de su propia Constitución quedaron
de facto derogados y se consideró, atentos,
a la reelección indefinida como un derecho
humano.
Vamos que limitar los mandatos y exigir alternancia
es un atentado a los derechos humanos.
[No, si al final Evo va a conseguir que el
mismísimo Uribe apoye su régimen.]
En fin, en serio… porque no es ninguna broma
que un político pueda hacer y deshacer con
las instituciones lo que le dé la gana. Eso
es peligroso, muy peligroso.
(En Bolivia el artículo 168 no se ha derogado
ni modificado. Lo que ocurre es que ahora
la Constitución boliviana tiene partes que
se cumplen y otras que no.
Todo esto es lo que ha desatado las protestas
contra esta deriva antidemocrática de Evo
Morales, dentro y fuera del país.)
Por supuesto, ante semejante espectáculo
varios miembros del Tribunal Electoral han
dimitido, y han sido sustituidos por personas
cercanas al propio partido de Evo Morales.
De esta forma, finalmente el pasado 4 de diciembre
de 2018, este órgano aprobó la candidatura
de Evo Morales a la presidencia y de Álvaro
Garcia Linera a la Vicepresidencia.
("Nada es tan peligroso como dejar permanecer
largo tiempo a un mismo ciudadano en el poder.
El pueblo se acostumbra a obedecerle y él
a mandarlo, de donde se originan la usurpación
y la tiranía”. Simón Bolivar)
Pero… un momento. Ya sé lo que alguno de
vosotros está pensando… Pero Enrique al
fin y al cabo va a haber unas elecciones…
si los bolivianos no le quieren pues que no
le voten, ¿verdad?
Pues amigos, esto tiene dos problemas:
Primero una democracia nunca, nunca puede
consistir en la tiranía de la mayoría sobre
la minoría. Las instituciones tienen que
respetarse y tienen que existir mecanismos
que le impidan a un político aferrarse al
poder mediante el uso de técnicas como el
voto clientelar, la dependencia del gobierno,
el control de los medios de comunicación
o simplemente la coacción.
El segundo problema tiene, precisamente, mucho
que ver con la obsesión que Evo Morales ha
demostrado por el poder.
En otras palabras: ¿hasta dónde está dispuesto
a llegar Evo Morales y su partido Movimiento
al Socialismo, el MAS; con tal de mantenerse
en el poder?
Evo perdió el Referéndum y aun así se presenta.
Ha movido cielo y tierra para ser de nuevo
candidato.
Así que ahora la pregunta es, ¿estará acaso
dispuesto a perder las elecciones o va a optar
en cambio por la estrategia de ganar cualquier
costa?
Me estoy refiriendo a la estrategia que ha
mantenido en el poder a personajes como Nicolás
Maduro, Daniel Ortega o Juan Orlando Hernández.
Esta es la pregunta que hoy muchos se hacen
en Bolivia. Y ojo, porque lo que ya ha conseguido
Evo Morales, además de ser el político boliviano
que más tiempo ha estado en el poder, es
que las instituciones de este país actúen
a su antojo.
(Bolivianos declaran a Evo Morales como “el
nuevo dictador”. Más de 150 organizaciones
civiles acordaron declarar a Evo Morales como
dictador y determinaron una agenda de actividades
en "defensa de la democracia". PanamPost)
En fin, amigos, aquí en VisualPolitik estaremos
muy, pero que muy atentos a lo que ocurra.
Pero ahora turno para ti, ¿Estás de acuerdo
con que Evo Morales se presente a la reelección?
Dejame tu respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta.
Por cierto, en un próximo vídeo vamos a
echar un vistazo a la Bolivia que ha construido
Evo Morales durante todos estos años al frente
del país.
Si no te lo quieres perder, ya lo sabes no
olvides suscibirte al VisualPolitik. Y si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante echanos
una mano dándole a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.